it's great to be joined today by
professor michael sandell professor of
political philosophy at harvard
university and also author of the
now in paperback book the tyranny of
merit can we find the common good it's
so great to have you on i appreciate
your time
good to be with you david so
to maybe start talking a little bit
about the the the topic of of merit
there's often sort of like two layers to
this discussion and one is a focus on an
argument as to whether we or a
particular country or society or economy
uh have a real meritocracy that's one
piece of the conversation the second
part which is less discussed but
arguably just as important if we really
did have a pure meritocracy would that
actually be a good thing what would be
the concerns what would be the problems
if it was really that everybody got what
they quote deserved from whatever sort
of perspective we want to approach that
question so
can can we maybe start with how we can
combine these two questions and enter
the kind of philosophy that that you lay
out in the book
yes and i do address both questions and
you're right to distinguish them it's
very important
the first problem with meritocracy is
that we don't live up to the
meritocratic principles we profess
in ivy league universities for example
there are more students from the top one
percent
than there are from students in families
in the bottom half of the income scale
combined
if you if you come from an affluent
family
top
uh the top quarter
you're
70 of the students who attend the 100
selected 100 plus most selective
colleges and universities 70 percent
come from the top quartile well-off
families
and do you know how many come from the
from the bottom quartile from low-income
families it must be incredibly small
it's three percent right
and now so we don't live up to the
meritocratic principles we profess it
isn't true as the slogan we hear from
politicians tells us
that you can make it if you try
that everyone really has an equal chance
to succeed so that's one problem with
meritocracy we we haven't realized it we
don't chances are not truly equal
but there's a deeper problem
which is that the ideal is flawed
and this is really the heart of my
argument in the tyranny of merit
meritocracy has a dark side
and the dark side is that it is
corrosive of the common good and let me
see if i can explain why because this is
a counterintuitive idea we normally
think that if only we could perfect the
meritocracy
then we would have a just society right
but think about it
if it were really true
that everyone's place in society
and in the income scale
were the result of their own doing
such that they could say i've earned it
i deserve my place
then
those who landed on top
would believe their success was their
own doing the measure of their merit
and they would look upon those who
struggle
as deserving their fate as well
in fact the person who coined the term
meritocracy he was a british sociologist
michael young in 1958
he coined it the rise of the meritocracy
was his book
as a dystopian scenario because he
glimpsed this he glimpsed the hubris
that a meritocracy
generates among the successful
and the humiliation
and resentment
it generates among those left behind now
you asked me david how do i bring these
two arguments together in the book
we've got in a way the worst of both
worlds
we don't have a true meritocracy because
opportunities are not truly equal
and yet
those who've landed on top especially in
recent decades
have come to believe
that their success is their own doing
and that they therefore deserve
the full measure of the benefits that a
market society showers upon them so we
have the hubris among the successful
we have the humiliation and the brewing
resentment understandable resentment
among those who struggle
even without a genuine meritocracy and
and i think that the anger and
resentment
among many working people
that elites meritocratic elites
credential lately looked down on them
that set of resentments and anger those
grievances
have gave rise to trump to donald trump
and they persist because the democratic
party really has become the party
of meritocratic credentialed elites
and has lost contact with
the working class
which once constituted its space going
back to the new deal
that's that's very interesting and
there's a lot of aspects there that that
we could dig more into
for because you mentioned political
party it seems that one of the i don't
even know that it's a side effect i mean
it's really a direct consequence of the
idea that everybody sort of has what
they've earned and what they've deserved
with equal opportunity it seems like
politically it's a recipe to justify
doing very little to help those whose
position is is lesser or less good
because after all it's a direct result
merely of their actions that they are
there and in fact it's this isn't
theoretical some of the primary
arguments made to cut welfare programs
uh against the so-called enhanced
unemployment during the pandemic that
we've seen against all of these things
is that
it's some form of laziness or simply
choosing one's circumstances why would
we reward people for that it has a very
direct line to policy
it does and we hear this argument all
the time
in debates about welfare and other forms
of income support
what's interesting
is the way
troubling but also important to come to
terms with
the way the democratic party has
migrated from being
a party that speaks
for the middle class and the working
class against the privilege
to being really the embodiment of
credent well-credentialed elites and the
professional classes and this happened
really over the last four decades
as the democratic party along with
republicans embraced
a kind of market-driven
finance-driven version of globalization
and education admonishing people to
improve themselves through higher
education that's been a big part of the
message especially of the democratic
party in the face of rising inequality
and wage stagnation
and job loss
over the last four decades
what we've heard from politicians
mainstream politicians
is not
an attempt to deal directly with
inequalities of income and wealth and
power
they've offered a kind of meritocratic
workaround
they've they've offered individual
upward mobility through higher education
if you want to compete and win in the
global economy
go to college what you earn will depend
on what you learn that was bill clinton
you can make it if you try that was
barack obama
but what they missed now it seems
inspiring to encourage everybody to go
to college or university
and increasing access broadening access
to higher education that's a good thing
i'd be the last person to argue against
that
but as a response or as the primary
response
to the rising inequality
of the globalization decades
and as a response
to the wage stagnation and job losses
experienced by many working people
that is a pale
offer
beca because those of us
it contains an implicit insult if you
think about it right
improve your condition
you will surmount wage stagnation and
job loss and inequality
the problem is that you aren't well
enough educated the problem is not that
we embraced policies that created this
widening gap it's that you are not well
enough educated so that was the insult
implicit in the seemingly inspiring
admonition
to go get a better education
and the result was
um
a rising resentment among people who
felt
that their concerns were not being taken
seriously yeah that's there's a couple
of interesting things there i mean so
we've seen a story that i first remember
hearing it um i think it was with rick
the senator from pennsylvania rick
santorum about maybe 20 years ago where
he started to say
uh you know we're
education is liberal indoctrination
we're never going to have those people
on our side because these mechanisms of
colleges and universities they're just
going to indoctrinate people into
left-wing sort of points of view
the left on the other hand has talked
about
let's get people college educations
let's look at free college let's look at
making it cheaper more accessible etc
and there's a couple of effects of that
one is that it's saying if and until you
do that you will be less than the people
that have done that but also isn't there
some degree to which if everybody went
ahead and did that
doesn't it sort of zero out and not even
actually solve the problems of
inequality that it claims to resolve
you're right it does not solve the
problem of inequality i think it's
desirable for its own sake
to make a college free and accept or at
least as accessible as possible yes the
people from every background that's a
good in and of itself and i'm all in
favor of it
but the question is whether that is an
adequate response
to the inequality and wage stagnation of
recent decades right and i say
it isn't
um first of all those of us who spend
our days in the company of credential of
the credentialed
can easily forget
a simple fact
most americans do not have a four-year
college degree
nearly two-thirds do not right so it's
folly
to
create an economy
that sets us unnecessary condition
of dignified work in a decent life
a college degree that most people don't
have
it also this way of thinking
is too too blinker to narrow an approach
to inequality
because it leaves in place the steep
hierarchy of prestige and esteem
associated with people
who
who are well credentialed right and it
implicitly disparages those who aren't
and this is embodied in in policy and in
funding
an economist at the brookings institute
figured uh institution figured out that
we spend
uh about
164 billion dollars a year helping
people go to college
and how much do we spend
supporting people who go in for
vocational and technical training
in community colleges
at the federal level about 1 billion 162
to 1. now there is there's something
wrong with that
mode of funding for those forms of
learning
including community colleges and
technical and vocational training
that many
people rely on to prepare themselves for
the world work but this this imbalance
reflects this broader
skewing of our values
in the direction of ballerizing people
who are well credentialed
and implicitly disparaging those
who have not been to university and this
is showing up in the way people are
voting
trump managed to tap into
the grievance
against elites that many working people
felt
and
you can look at the voting behavior in
the last few decades
as a college the college-educated vote
has gone increasingly for democrats
and
the vote among those who haven't been to
college goes increasingly for
republicans
and especially uh republicans like trump
of an authoritarian populist bent who
channel the anger and the sense of
grievance and what's interesting is the
similar pattern is unfolding in britain
and in france and in other countries
that have embraced globalization
uh emphasized the meritocratic uh
solution
to inequality
and have alienated center-left parties
now there's there are some who would
look at that phenomenon that you
identify of the college educated voter
voting more for democrats voting more
for center-left and left-wing parties in
the uk and say well this is there's a
very simple intuitive explanation for
that as you become more educated and you
learn more about the world you realize
it's better for everybody it's better
for the country to vote for these people
you're doing an altruistic thing you're
doing a rational thing and we're all
better off for it
right
and that in itself i think is a
hubristic
analysis of the situation because in
fact
the policies the kind of finance driven
globalization or neoliberal
policies
embraced by
center right center left parties really
center left and center right but
politically the toll has been taken upon
the democratic party in the u.s the
labor party in britain the socialist
party in france
these policies
have failed
and the 2008 financial crisis was the
most dramatic illustration of how a kind
of finance driven globalization project
fails
the recession that followed
which fell very heavily on low and
middle income
americans
demonstrate demonstrated further the
failure and then to add insult to injury
is the meritocratic uh attempt to say
that the solution to to inequality and
wage stagnation is not to reconsider the
policies that we
promoted and enacted for 30 or 40 years
it's simply for you to improve
yourselves there's something deeply
disparaging about that so i think that
what i'm proposing for the democratic
party is a shift
to focus less
on arming people for meritocratic
competition and to focus more on the
dignity of work to ask what would it
take to make life better
for everyone regardless of of the
university credentials they may have and
we we could explore and there will be
debates about what counts what policies
actually support and affirm the dignity
of work but i think that should be the
starting point
last thing i want to touch on are there
societies that we can look at either
today or historically that have had
maybe what we would call a more balanced
or productive or rational view on the
kind of interaction between merit and
equality that might be interesting as a
model in some sense
well in some ways and this is not to uh
engage in golden age nostalgia but
the political coalitions that formed uh
during the time of fdr in the new deal
were an example of coalitions that did
not depend
on admonishing working people to improve
themselves but instead ask how can we
structurally reform the economy
to
strengthen
collective bargaining to strengthen
unions to give working people more of a
voice more of a say as well as to to be
able to negotiate better working
conditions i think today
in some ways
uh biden
has begun to depart from
the meritocratic technocratic neoliberal
orientation of his predecessors and it's
interesting to notice
that
joe biden was the first democratic
nominee in 36 years
without an ivy league degree this may
have opened him at least a little
to a broader horizon he speaks more
actually about the dignity of work than
he does
about meritocratic striving and
meritocratic competition there's also an
interesting political figure now you've
been looked at the german elections the
social democratic
candidate olaf schultz
has been trying to make this shift as
well to focus he's actually offered a
critique
of the single-minded focus on merit and
has emphasized instead notions of
respect and the dignity of work
and i think that this is a more
promising direction for the democratic
party and for center-left parties
generally i could not uh could not agree
more and much of what we've been talking
about today
is in the just out in paperback book the
tyranny of merit can we find the common
good we've been speaking with the book's
author professor michael sandell from
harvard university so appreciate your
time and your insights today
thank you david